E
PRICE ON THOSE COUNTRIES AS WELL
AND YOU'RE RIGHT IT
MAKES NO SENSE.
AINSLEY: LET'S BRING IN MIKE
POMPEO, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTE OR
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE GOOD
MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU ALL.
AINSLEY: WE'LL START WITH YOUR
REACTION ON DR. FAUCI AND
EVERYTHING THAT'S COMING OUT
WITH HIM, LATELY.
HE HAD HIS FIRST INTERVIEW WITH
NICOLE WALLACE YESTERDAY AND SHE
REALLY DIDN'T GRILL HIM ABOUT
THOSE E-MAILS.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION ABOUT THESE
3,200 PAGES OF E-MAILS?
>> SO I'VE SEEN SOME OF THE
E-MAILS.
WHAT REALLY MATTERS HERE IS WHEN
IT MATTERED MOST, WHEN THE
CHINESE WERE COVERING THIS
UP IN EARLY JANUARY OF 2020
, DR. FAUCI CERTAINLY WOULD
HAVE SEEN THE SAME INTELLIGENCE
THAT I SAW.
WE WOULD CERTAINLY HAVE KNOWN
THAT THE RISK THIS CAME FROM THE
LABORATORY WAS REAL AND THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
DIDN'T WANT ANY OF US TO KNOW
THAT AND THAT RAISED RED FLAGS
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT FOR FAR TOO
LONG.
DR. FAUCI LET THOSE OF US WHO
WERE OUT THERE TALKING ABOUT IT
CARRY THE MANTEL, AND WE
COULDN'T GET SCIENCE.
WE GOT POLITICS INSTEAD AND
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAW ON THE LEFT
WING MEDIA.
POLITICS TRUMPING SCIENCE AND
THAT DELAYED OUR CAPACITY TO
RESPOND TO WHAT THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY PUT UPON THE
WORLD.
BRIAN:  DIRECTLY AFFECTS OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
HERE IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
E-MAILS THAT ARE EYE BROW
RAISING THIS IS AN E-MAIL, THIS
IS WHAT HE'S RESPONDING
AFTER ANTHONY FAUCI SIDELINED
THE TALK OF A LAB LEAK.
"APRIL 18, 2020 I'M SURE YOU
REMEMBER THIS.
I JUST WANT TO SAY A PERSONAL
THANK YOU, ON BEHALF OF OUR
STAFF AND COLLABORATORS, FOR
PUBLICLY STANDING UP AND
STATING THAT THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE SUPPORTS A NATURAL
ORIGIN FROM COVID-19 FROM A BAT
TO A HUMAN SPILLOVER, NOT A LAB
RELEASE FROM THE WUHAN INSTITUTE
OF VIROLOGY, FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
YOUR COMMENTS ARE BRAVE AND
COMING FROM YOUR TRUSTED VOICE
WILL HELP DISPELL THE MYTHS
BEING SPUN AROUND THE VIRUSES
ORIGINS."
NOW YOUR JOB, SECRETARY OF STATE
, KNOWING THAT THAT WAS
GOING ON BEHIND THE SCENES,
ANTHONY FAUCI SAYING IT HAPPENED
BY HAPPEN STANCE, WET MARKET AS
OPPOSED TO A WUHAN LAB, WHERE
TOM COTTON WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
TO SAY, LET'S LOOK AT THAT LAB.
>> YEAH, SO RIGHT AFTER THAT
E-MAIL THAT YOU DESCRIBED IN
EARLY MAY I BEGAN TO TALK
ABOUT THIS AS WELL.
WE KNEW THAT THE EVIDENCE WAS
ACCUMULATING.
IT WAS PILING UP SHOWING THAT
THE THEORY OF THE WET MARKET
DIDN'T HOLD WATER AND THAT THE
MUCH MORE LIKELY SCENARIO
WITH THIS HAD COME FROM THE
VIROLOGY LAB IN WUHAN, AND
THIS GUY, THE FELLOW THAT WROTE
THIS E-MAIL.
HE'S GOT DIRTY HANDS.
HE WAS INVOLVED IN THIS
LABORATORY.
THERE WAS TAXPAYER MONEY FUNNEL
ED THROUGH AN  ALLIANCE HE
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR.
YOU KNOW, TOO, BRIAN HE WAS ONE
OF THE LEAD INVESTIGATORS THAT
WAS SENT INTO TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS.
BRIAN:  WHAT A JOKE.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS
TO BE ANSWERED AND I THINK DR.
FAUCI HAS A LOT OF QUESTIONS
TO ANSWER AND THIS MATTERS, YOUR
POINT BRIAN ABOUT THIS BEING
ABOUT AMERICAN NATIONAL SECURITY
THAT LAB IS STILL OPERATING.
THAT WORK IS STILL GOING ON
THERE TODAY, AND WE COULD HAVE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPEN AGAIN
IN THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
REFUSE TO TELL US WHAT THEY KNOW
THE UNITED STATES, PRESIDENT
BIDEN, MUST DEMAND THAT WE GET
THESE ANSWERS AND WE NEED TO
KNOW HOW THE U.S. GOVERNMENT,
HOW THE U.S. GOVERNMENT, DR.
FAUCI, ALL THE FOLKS
INVOLVED IN UNDERWRITING THIS
LABORATORY WHAT THEY KNEW,
WHEN THEY KNEW IT BECAUSE THIS
WILL HELP US ANSWER THE
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS THAT
WILL KEEP US ALL SAFE.
>> OKAY THAT'S THE PERFECT
SEGWAY TO THE QUESTION I HAVE
FOR YOU, MR. SECRETARY.
YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN A STRAIGHT
SHOOTER.
WE KNOW THERE WERE SOME BEHIND
THE SCENES SCUFFLES BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND FAUCI AND YOU
GUYS.
DID YOU ALL KNOW SOMETHING WAS
GOING ON BEHIND THE SCENES, THAT
THERE WAS THIS CONNECTION BACK
THEN?
WHAT DID YOU GUYS KNOW AT THE
TIME?
>> SO I HAVE TO BE A LITTLE
CAREFUL.
YOU SAW, LAWRENCE, WHAT WE WERE
ABLE TO RELEASE ON JANUARY 15,
DIRECTOR RATCLIFFE, THE HEAD OF
THE  DNI HAD BEEN WORKING FOR A
LONG TIME TO GET AS MUCH
INFORMATION RELEASED AS WE
POSSIBLY COULD.
WE KNEW, WE COULD WATCH ALL OF
THE FACTS BEGIN TO ALIGN THAT
SUGGESTED THAT THE MOST LIKELY
CASE, WE KNEW ABOUT THE DOCTORS,
WE WATCHED THEM DISAPPEAR,
JOURNALISTS, WE KNEW PEOPLE HAD
TAKEN ILL IN WUHAN.
WE BEGAN TO SEE THE EVIDENCE
ACCUMULATE AND WE WERE TRYING TO
GET IT OUT.
WE WERE CERTAINLY TRYING TO MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY IN THE UNITED
STATES SO WE COULD RESPOND.
>> SORRY TO INTERRUPT.
WHAT PREVENTED YOU GUYS FROM
PUSHING OUT ALL OF THE
INFORMATION?
>> IT'S COMPLICATED PROCESS,
LAWRENCE.
THERE'S STILL MORE INFORMATION
SITTING THERE THAT I THINK OUGHT
TO BE OUT, BUT YOU HAVE SOURCES
AND METHODS, INTELLIGENCE AND
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE PROTECTED
I WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE CIA, I
UNDERSTAND THAT, BUT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE KNOW EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN, AND THEN FRANKLY, WE DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER FOR SURE.
WE NEED THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
AINSLEY: WILL WE EVER KNOW THE
ANSWER, THE ORIGINS OF THIS
VIRUS THAT KILLED MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD?
>> YEAH, I THINK WE WILL.
IT MAY TAKE YEARS AND YEARS AND
YEARS.
WE KNOW IT HAS ALREADY TAKEN TOO
LONG.
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
COULD ANSWER THIS IN 30 SECONDS
IF THEY CHOSE TO DO SO BUT I
THINK ONE DAY WE'LL KNOW.
SOME BRAVE CHINESE DOCTOR, SOME
TECHNICIAN WILL BREAK FREE AND
SHARE THE INFORMATION.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO VALIDATE WHAT
HAPPENED.
WE NEED TO GET THE ANSWER TO
THIS QUESTION.
BRIAN:  RIGHT I WILL SAY THIS
JUST IN TERMS OF WHAT
E-MAILS SUBSCRIBE TO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING, THIS EXCHANGE BETWEEN
THE SCIENTIST RICHARD HENDERSON
TO FAUCI, HE SAID UNUSUAL
FEATURES ON THE VIRUS MAKEUP A
REALLY SMALL PART OF THE GENOME,
SO ONE HAS TO LOOK AT VERY HARD
AT ALL OF THE SEQUENCES TO SEE
THAT SOME OF THE FEATURES
POTENTIALLY LOOK ENGINEERED.
ISN'T THAT NICE?
SO, THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
MANUFACTURED AND MADE.
>> BRIAN, YOU KNOW, ALL THESE
E-MAILS THAT YOU'RE SEEING NOW
ARE ENTIRELY CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT THE PROPAGANDA MACHINE
INSIDE OF CHINA WAS PRESSING AND
WHAT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION WAS PRESSING AS
WELL.
WE CAN'T FORGET THAT ALL THIS
TIME, NOT ONLY WAS THERE AN
ABSENCE OF INFORMATION FROM
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY, BUT
THEY WERE TRYING TO TELL US THIS
CAME FROM AMERICA.
THEY WERE --
BRIAN:  THEY STILL DO.
>> ENGAGED IN PROPAGANDA
SUGGESTING THIS WAS NATURAL.
THEY ARE HARD AT IT.
WE'VE GOT TO HOLD THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY ACCOUNTABLE.
I HAVEN'T SEEN ANY EVIDENCE THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS PREPARED
TO DO THAT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD
DEMAND THEY BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THERE ARE LOTS OF TOOLS WE CAN
USE TO DO THAT.
>> MR. SECRETARY, I WANT TO
PIVOT TO ANOTHER ISSUE, KAMALA
HARRIS HAS GONE 71 DAYS WITHOUT
A PRESS CONFERENCE BEING TAPPED
TO RUN THE BORDER CRISIS.
NOW SHE'LL BE AT GUATEMALA ON
SUNDAY AND MEXICO ON MONDAY.
WE KNOW THAT YOU BRIEFED THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DURING
THE TRANSITION ABOUT HOW THEIR
POLICY COULD IMPACT THE BORDER,
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY.
WHAT SHOULD SHE BE SAYING TO
THESE COUNTRIES WHEN SHE GOES TO
MEET WITH THEM, THIS UPCOMING
WEEK?
>> UNFORTUNATELY, SHE'S NOT
GOING TO SAY WHAT NEEDS TO BE
SAID.
WHAT IS EASY TO DO IS TO JUST GO
BACK TO THE POLICIES THAT WE HAD
IN PLACE, ONCE THEY WORKED.
IT TOOK US A LITTLE WHILE TO GET
THEM IN PLACE, BUT WE TURNED
OFF THE MAGNET.
WE HAD PREVENTED THIS MASSIVE
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
AND THIS ENORMOUS NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS FROM TAKING
PLACE.
SHE SHOULD TELL THEM WE'RE GOING
TO GO BACK TO THE POLICIES THAT
WE HAD BACK IN DECEMBER OF LAST
YEAR, AND THIS WILL KEEP THOSE
COUNTRIES WANT TO KEEP
THEIR PEOPLE TOO.
THEY LIKE TO HAVE THEIR TALENT
STAY INSIDE OF THEIR COUNTRY.
WE NEED TO TELL THEM THAT THIS
IS WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO.
THEY HAVE TO ENFORCE THEIR OWN
BORDERS AND WE'RE GOING TO
ENFORCE OURS.
AINSLEY: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
RUSSIA MEETING COMING UP
BETWEEN JOE BIDEN AND VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
WE KEEP SEEING ALL OF THESE
RANSOMWARE ATTACKS, AND THEY'RE
BEING LINKED TO RUSSIA.
A REPORTER WAS ASKING JEN PSAKI
ABOUT IT IN THE PRESS ROOM
YESTERDAY, AND THEY SAY THAT
THEY'RE NOT BEING TESTED BY
PUTIN.
LISTEN TO THIS AND WE'LL GET
YOUR REACTION.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WILL YOU
RETALIATE AGAINST RUSSIA FOR THE
LATEST RANSOMWARE ATTACK
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> DO YOU THINK PUTIN IS
TESTING YOU?
>> NO.
AINSLEY: HE SAYS PUTIN IS NOT
TESTING HIM.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> HERE IS WHAT I CAN SAY FOR
SURE.
THESE KINDS OF THINGS IN OUR
ADMINISTRATION WERE DIFFERENT
AND KIND IN THE RESPONSES TO
RUSSIAN ACTIVITY WAS DIFFERENT
IN KIND.
WE DIDN'T GIVE THE MONEY.
WE DIDN'T LET THEM BUILD-OUT
THEIR ENERGY PIPELINE.
WE PROVIDED WEAPON SYSTEMS TO
THE UKRAINE TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
, WE BUILT OUT OUR
MILITARY, ALL THESE THINGS
VLADIMIR PUTIN DIDN'T LIKE AND
NOW YOU SEE THESE RANSOMWARE
ATTACKS.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THE INTELLIGENCE
BUT THEY LOOK AND HAVE ALL OF
THE HALLMARKS OF HAVING COME
FROM RUSSIA, WHEN PRESIDENT
BIDEN MEETS WITH PRESIDENT PUTIN
NEXT WEEK HE NEEDS TO MAKE CLEAR
THERE WILL BE REAL COSTS, NOT
JUST ON THESE THUGS, THESE
CRIMINALS WHO ARE ENGAGED IN
THIS CONDUCT BUT FROM THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE SUPPORTING AND ENABLING
IF IT IN FACT IS COMING FROM
INSIDE OF RUSSIA.
VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS AN AWFUL LOT
OF CAPACITY TO CONTROL WHAT
HAPPENS INSIDE OF HIS COUNTRY,
AND THE LEADERS OF THAT COUNTRY
NEED TO BE HELD THIBLE IF WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE THING
WHICH IS CAN REEK ENORMOUS
DEVASTATION ON OUR ECONOMY.
BRIAN:  THEY SAID IT.
THEY HAD THEIR UNDERSECRETARY
COME OUT AND SAY
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THINGS VERY
UNPLEASANT FOR THE PRESIDENT
LEADING UP TO JUNE 16, AND NOW,
THEY'VE TAKEN OUT THE  MTA
THROUGH RANSOMWARE, JBS
, THE COLONIAL
PIPELINE AND THE MASSACHUSETTS
STEAMBOAT AUTHORITY LET ALONE
WHAT JUST HAPPENED WITH THIS
MEAT HIT, IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE COUNTRY.
SO THIS IS A, THEY KEEP GETTING
SHOTS TO THE FOREHEAD AND WE
DON'T ANSWER WITH ANYTHING.
>> [LAUGHTER]
YEAH, BRIAN.
THESE ARE THE WINS THAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THAT HAVE BEEN MADE PUBLIC
GOODNESS KNOWS HOW MANY HAVE
TAKEN PLACE INSIDE SOME PRIVATE
COMPANY WHO JUST DECIDED TO PAY
THE RANSOM TO MAKE IT GO AWAY.
WE'LL HAVE TO IMPOSE REAL COSTS
AND DEFEND OURSELVES AND BRIAN
WE HAVE LOTS OF TOOLS SOME OF
WHICH WE CAN'T SAY MUCH ABOUT
BUT WE HAVE LOTS OF TOOLS WHERE
WE CAN IMPOSE REAL COST ON THE
RUSSIANS AND THE CYBER HACK
ERS.
THIS IS A SOVEREIGNTY ISSUE,
THIS IS NOT TERRIBLY DIFFERENT
FROM SOMEONE WHO ATTACKS THE
UNITED STATES IN THE WAYS
WE'VE KNOWN AS A MATTER OF
HISTORY AND WE NEED TO TREAT IT
AS JUST THAT KIND OF ATTACK.
>> MR. SECRETARY, WE WANT TO
PIVOT TO THIS STORY RIGHT HERE.
NETANYAHU RIVALS TO FORM A NEW
GOVERNMENT TO OUST HIM.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR THE U.S.
ISRAEL RELATIONS?
THIS IS ISRAEL'S LONGEST SERVING
PRIME MINISTER, OUR MOST TRUSTED
ALLIE.
WILL THAT RELATIONSHIP AND THAT
BOND REMAIN WITH THIS NEW
GOVERNMENT?
>> LAWRENCE I WAS IN ISRAEL
THIS PAST WEEKEND FOR FOUR DAYS
WHILE THIS WAS ALL TAKING PLACE.
THIS GOVERNMENT IS CONFUSING ONE
, THAT THEY ARE TRYING TO
FORM.
IT'S NOT COMPLETELY OVER YET.
IT'S NOT CERTAIN THAT THEY WILL
BE SUCCESSFUL IN DOING SO.
YOU'VE GOT ARAB PARTIES, YOU'VE
GOT HARD RIGHT PARTY, YOU'VE GOT
WHAT BE TRADITIONALLY THE
ISRAELI CENTER LEFT PARTY.
THIS IS GOING TO BE REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS AND THAT'S NOT GOOD
FOR THE U.S. ISRAEL RELATIONSHIP
I HOPE THAT WHATEVER GOVERNMENT
GETS FORMED CONTINUES TO BUILD
ON THIS IMPORTANT SECURITY
RELATIONSHIP.
WE WERE SUCH GREAT PARTNERS WITH
THE ISRAEL.
WE WERE ABLE TO ISOLATE THEM AS
PART OF THE ABRAHAM ACCORD.
I HOPE THAT WHATEVER GOVERNMENT
ULTIMATELY TAKES PLACE THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO BUILD-OUT ON WHAT WE
DID WHICH REALLY CREATED MORE
PEACE, MORE PROSPERITY AND
INDEED MORE STABILITY IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
BRIAN:  WELL PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
NETANYAHU FAMOUSLY DISLIKED EACH
OTHER.
IN FACT PRESIDENT OBAMA WORKED
ON THE SCENES HE WOULDN'T GET
RE-ELECTED WHICH IS
UNBELIEVABLE AND JOE BIDEN NO
WORD YET ON HOW THIS IS GOING TO
AFFECT RELATIONS BUT WHEN YOU
HAVE TO MAKE A DEAL WITH AN ARAB
SECTOR OF THE ISRAELI GOVERNMENT
, THIS IS
UNPRECEDENTED, SO WHAT DO THEY
GIVE UP?
WHAT DO THEY PROMISE?
>> IT'LL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
, BRIAN WHAT ALL DEALS HAD
TO BE CUT TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
IF THEY DON'T GET IT DONE THERE
WILL BE A FIFTH ELECTION IT'S
MESSY STUFF INSIDE OF ISRAEL BUT
BRIAN WE CAN SEE WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THE UNITED STATES ISN'T
STRONG.
THE IRANIANS WILL UNDERWRITE
HEZBOLLAH, WE SAW
WHAT THEY DID WITH FIRING ROCKET
S INTO TEL AVIV AND
JERUSALEM, AND AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP WITH ISRAEL MATTERS A
LOT AND WHATEVER GOVERNMENT GETS
FORMED IN ISRAEL BUILDS ON THAT.
AINSLEY: THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING ON WITH US.
>> THANK YOU, SECRETARY.